Hello Freak bitches,
let me use another example because I think this will help show what's happening
here.
So there was a,
uh,
a Chinese,
a site,
you know,
most drug trials,
they take place at different sites so they have multiple locations that are
testing so that they can get data on different populations,
you know,
not just in white Americans,
also Chinese people and you know,
so they do it different centers.
And so there was a,
it was a trial for an anticoagulant drug.
Um,
and uh,
they found that this Chinese center had falsified a whole bunch of patient data
and change the results and if they took that Chinese center's data out of the
equation,
that drug would have failed.
It wouldn't have been more effective than placebo.
But even though the FDA busted this group in China,
the study that was published on that drug still included that data from the
study in China and even studies that were being published 18 months later still
included that data in the original data set.
So the FDA busted them.
It was clear that they had falsified the data and yet that data is still being
included in the studies that doctors are relying on all over the world to make
decisions about whether to prescribe these drugs.
So there's,
there's fraud happening and whether it's,
you know,
from financial interests or just human error that's not actually being reported
and translating into clinical decisions that,
that doctors are making.
So there are a lot of.
And then the whole peer review process,
you mentioned peer review to a,
there was a pretty big study where,
um,
the,
uh,
paper was submitted to Bmj,
British Medical Journal and other big medical journal with eight major errors
and not a single one of the 221 scientists that were asked to review the paper,
caught all of the errors and only 30 percent recommended rejecting the paper.
And this was even more problematic because half of those scientists were warned
in advance.
We're going to give you a paper that has a lot of errors.
And,
and the ones who were warned didn't get any more of the errors than the
scientists that weren't warned in advance.
They broke them up into two groups.
Is that just a lack of time to do the research and people being overwhelmed by a
workload?
I think that's probably part of it.
Um,
but it's not really an excuse.
I don't know.
I mean it's just,
it's a problem with peer review because our artist,
you know,
it is a big part of the scientific method to,
to have the results validated by somebody else or,
or two to review the work and make sure that it sounds.
But what this paper indicated is that a lot of findings that we take to be true
and valid might not actually be true and valid.
And you may have heard about this,
it actually made the news,
um,
there was a recent,
the open science collaboration did a review of one psychology studies and that
had never been replicated.
Replicating findings is really important in the scientific method to like if you
design a study and you do it and you have,
you find a certain result in science,
it's not really considered to be valid unless I do it and,
and confirm your results,
you know,
or someone else does.
It's independent of you.
And in a shocking number of studies,
this never happens.
And so they,
this group went back and looked at 100 psychology studies and tried to replicate
them using the,
you know,
almost identical conditions from the original studies and they were only able to
do that in 35 percent of cases there.
Uh,
another group looked at a precancer,
a clinical studies and found that could only replicate 11 percent of those.
It's a well known saying in the pharmaceutical world that,
that,
like more than half of the drug trials can't be replicated.
And have a group of researchers from Bayer,
from a pharmaceutical company tried to do that in 2011.
They took a bunch of trials and try to replicate them less than one quarter.
Then they were able to replicate the results.
So what this means is,
you know,
a study can be done,
it's never validated and then a whole bunch of other studies are done that refer
to that study and whole fields of scientific research are spawn on a study that
was never confirmed or validated.
So it's like a house of cards built on a foundation of falsehood.
Well,
so you know,
science is great.
We need to keep improving science,
but there's a lot of problems with the way that studies are performed right now
and it Kinda,
it's,
it's both,
you know,
conflicts of interest that are based on money and it's just also human human
error.
Are
these black mold spores just being poisoned all the time.
Do they have home tests for that?
I bet you anything.
I have so much black,
black people,
fucking son of a bitch.
He's
got to keep an eye on it.
Help the jokes.
They come,
they just come.
I hit a bunch of mold the other day.
It's late at night and we bought strawberries.
You know like underneath the strawberry was like green and stuff.
I had no idea because it was dark.
I was eating strawberries and the next day I go in to get some more and I'm
like,
they're all moldy.
I'm like,
was I eating?
I was eating moldy strawberry in the dark.
Yeah,
man.
It's probably not even that bad for you.
It's probably just all in your head.
I mean,
otherwise people would be dying left and right,
right,
right.
Because everybody eats strawberries and doesn't pay attention.
I didn't realize people actually could pass up behind a dumpster late.
I've never been that drunk to where that's where I would lay down.
I fucked by a dumpster but never slept there.
He fucked by a dumpster,
like call that dumpster grease on the ground now.
Slippery to boxes down,
but oh my God,
what a classy girl you must have been.
I told you about this and the guy came out and he caught us having sex and he's
like,
oh,
you got nervous.
He's like,
do you guys want some pizza?
Because he thought
we were homeless.
Homeless Bank to homeless people,
Bang on pizza boxes next to dumpsters.
That's pretty much it.
You heard this media narrative that it sells papers.
It sell,
it didn't sell clicks at the time because they were doing,
it's about the Internet,
but it sells papers,
which is the idea that the internet is a haven of crooks and fraudsters and
terrorists and pedophiles and pornography.
Great.
Yes.
Criminal use of advanced technology,
criminal use,
the most advanced technology they can get their hands on because they're in a
very highly competitive,
high margin,
high risk business.
And of course they're going to say they criminals wear shoes to run away from
bank heist criminals drive cars to get away from raw bank robberies.
They use cell phones to coordinate with each other.
They drink water.
So it does not to die of dehydration.
We're not going to ban all of those things.
Right?
And so you have that anger.
Um,
and they tried that for awhile.
every time they try that,
you just turn around and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
actually the biggest money launderers of drugs in the world are HSBC,
the Hong Kong,
Hong Kong,
Shanghai banking consortium.
Inconvenient fact is that laundry is in the world.
Yes.
They would call it the model.
New Laundering,
$700,000,000,000 for the Sinaloa cartel over a period of 10 years during which
19,000 people died in Mexico as a direct result of that.
Um,
and they got a fine and no one went to jail.
So there are inconvenient facts like that.
Every time they say bitcoin fund's terrorism,
you say,
ah,
I see them driving Toyota's and Humvees,
uh,
that doesn't,
that's a bit incongruence.
Like they're,
they're driving around in the vehicles.
We left behind and there they got a lot of their funding from pallets of money
that we left behind and they're getting paid for dollar in dollars for oil that
they're selling to our closest allies.
We shouldn't really mentioned Saudi Arabia.
Um,
so these are the inconvenient truth,
right?
So you don't talk about these in polite company or at least you do.
Like,
that's what I said when I was invited to speak in front of the Senate in Canada
and they started asking me about terrorism and I said to actually mostly funded
by our allies.
And what did they say when you do that?
That was the end of that train of thought.
They stopped,
you know,
it was live public tv,
but what,
what,
like what went down when we moved on to talk about more realistic and
interesting things in a much more positive view of what this thing is.
So they tried to discredit bitcoin by attaching it to terrorism and you informed
them of the facts of where terrorists are actually funded from.
Yes.
In a very public forum on live TV,
which was very difficult to continue that line of conversation.
So that's anger.
Is there a resistance in Canada?
Like there isn't the United States where.
No,
actually,
um,
they,
they've been very,
very positive,
very positive to,
towards,
towards cryptocurrencies in general.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And there's a lot of.